in this episode of Klaudia adventures
find out how to train on increasingly
complex datasets by converting a linear
model to a deep neural network as the
number of Fischer columns in a linear
model grows it can be increasingly
difficult to achieve high accuracies in
your training as the interactions
between different columns get more
complex this is a known problem and one
particularly effective solution for data
scientists to use is deep neural
networks deep neural networks are able
to adapt to more complex datasets and
better generalize to previously unseen
data because of its multiple layers
that's why they're called deep these
layers allow them to fit more complex
datasets and linear models can however
the trade-off is that the model will
generally tend to take longer to Train
be larger in size and have less
interpretability
so why would anyone want to use it
because it can lead to higher final
accuracies on this complicated dataset
one of the tricky things about deep
learning is that getting all the
parameters to be just right can be very
tough depending on your data set the
configurations can seem virtually
limitless
however tensor flows built in deep
classifier and deep progressor classes
supply a reasonable set of defaults and
you can get started with right away
allowing you to get going quickly and
easily let's see an example of how to
update our iris example from a linear
model to a deep neural network often
abbreviated as DN n now we don't have
time in this video to properly show off
a 2,000 column model that a DNN would
leverage so I'm just gonna use the four
that we've been using throughout this
series the main change comes from
replacing our linear classifier class
with DNN classifier this will create a
deep neural network for us virtually
everything else remains the same there
is one additional parameter that is
required for the deep neural network
that we did not include previously since
deep neural networks have multiple
layers and each layer has potentially a
different number of nodes we'll add a
hidden units argument the hidden units
argument allows you to supply an array
with the number of no
for each layer this allows you to create
a neural network simply by considering
its size and shape rather than writing
the whole thing from scratch by hand and
wiring everything up adding or removing
layers is as simple as adding or
removing an element in the array of
course with any pre-constructed system
will you gain inconvenience you often
lose in customizability DNN classifier
tries to get around this by including a
number of additional parameters that you
can optionally use we left out some
reasonable bold defaults are utilized
for example the optimizer the activation
function and drop out ratios are all
available to customize along with many
others what else do you have to do in
order to convert our model from linear
to deep nothing that's the beauty of
using the estimators framework one
common way to organize your data
training evaluation and model exporting
while still giving you the flexibility
to experiment with different models and
different parameters sometimes deep
neural networks can outperform linear
models in these situations tensorflow
makes it easy to switch from a linear
model to a deep one with very little
code changes by leveraging the
estimators framework to replace just one
function call this means more time to
work on the data model and parameters
rather than wiring up your training loop
I'm Yu Feng Guo if you want to learn
more be sure to subscribe to the channel
and check out the rest of Klaudia
adventures don't forget to use
tensorflow
estimators for easy deep neural networks
thanks for watching that episode cloud
AI adventures you can catch the whole
series here and if you have any thoughts
and comments feel free to leave them
down below
[Music]